Rishi Sonic perfect thank you Gareth hi
everyone how are you
[Applause]
I was going to say actually this is what
an incredible place so congratulations
for working here and thank you for
having me it's brilliant to be here with
Ikea and wincanton I must say
everything's been superb so far although
my team were a little bit sad that there
were no meatballs at lunch
um but I don't know how your canteen
works but other than that it's been
brilliant so thank you for having me now
I think yesterday you would have heard
some news about inflation today you may
have seen what the bank of England has
announced with interest rates and I'm
sure that actually fills many of you
with some anxiety right and some concern
about what's going on and what does that
mean for you and your families now I'm
here to tell you that I am totally 100
on it and it is going to be okay and we
are going to get through this and that
is the most important thing I wanted to
let you know today now you should know
like I know this won't make it any
easier but what we're grappling with
here is something that many countries
around the world are all program
grappling with at the same time as we
are right now so if you look at interest
rates in Australia or in Canada in New
Zealand across the world they're all at
high levels actually interest rates in
Europe the highest they've been in for
20 years because they're all grappling
with inflation in the same way that we
are many of you may have friends or
family in those places and if you spoke
to them they tell you the same thing now
that doesn't make it any easier of
course I know that but it's important
for you to know that we're not alone in
dealing with this and I know how
important this is and that's why at the
beginning of the year I made a speech
and I set out my five priorities for the
country that I wanted to deliver as your
prime minister the first of those was to
halve inflation
I know how important this is that's why
I said it as my top priority and look
it's not easy right routing out
inflation is not easy it requires
difficult decisions doesn't happen
overnight but if we don't get on top of
it it would just get worse and it would
last longer and that's not going to do
anyone any favors it's not going to be
good for you and your families in the
long run and even though it means I have
to make some difficult decisions that's
the type of prime minister I am because
I want to do the right thing for you and
your families in the long term now look
why does inflation matter right like why
why why did it matter to me why did I
set it as my top priority is it's pretty
simple it's because inflation eats into
the pounds in your pocket it's as simple
as that makes us everybody poorer it
means prices go up it means your savings
get eroded it puts jobs and livelihoods
at risk and that's why it's so important
that we target it and get it down that's
why I said I wanted to halve it on its
way to getting it back down to two
percent where it belongs and I am
absolutely confident
that if we hold our nerve and stick to
our plan we will do that right then you
should feel the same confidence that I
do because we are going to get through
this and we're going to get this done
now why do I feel confident what is that
plan I'm talking about well three parts
to it the first is I've got to make sure
government is doing everything that it
needs to do and that means being
responsible with our borrowing right
because we cannot in a situation a
situation like this borrow too much
money because that much makes everything
worse so that means much as I would love
to
I'd love to cut your taxes tomorrow
right you love that I'd love that of
course I would right that's hard to do
because it means I have to borrow more
money to do it right another thing is I
can't say yes to every single thing that
people want me to spend more money on
right because that would mean we would
have to borrow money to do all of that
that means I have to make some difficult
choices I have to prioritize same as all
of you do in your household budgets I
have to do the same thing too and it
means when we're trying to figure out
how we pay all our fantastic public
sector workers I need to think about
what's affordable what's responsible
again so I can manage our borrowing now
none of those things I talked about are
easy right those are all difficult
decisions that I have to make but if I
just gave into the easy thing every time
that would just mean more and more
government borrowing that just puts fuel
on the fire makes inflation worse pushes
up interest rates even higher so even
though it's tough for me in the short
term doesn't make my life easy anyone
who tells you that it would be easy
isn't being straight with you I want to
be straight with you that means I do
have to make these difficult decisions
but that's the right thing to do it's
the right thing to do for you and your
families in the long run and that's why
I'm going to stick to the course and
manage our borrowing now the second part
of the plan is making sure that we
tackle all those areas where inflation
is particularly bad right energy is an
obvious one right the bills that you've
had to pay over the last year have been
extraordinary right absolutely
extraordinary never seen anything like
it now I'm pleased they're going to be
starting to come down right so bills are
going to come down about 430 quid
starting in July that's good news
the worst of this and they'll keep
coming down after that but that's just
now we need to make sure this doesn't
happen again and that they keep coming
down that means we need to have more
energy so we're investing more in
renewable energy like offshore wind
building new nuclear power stations but
also making sure that we get more energy
here at home from the North Sea more oil
and gas which we're going to need for
the next few decades as we transition to
a cleaner future so we're investing in
that too now food is another area where
your weekly shop right has gone up far
too much in in the past few months
especially so we're looking at the
supermarkets making sure that they're
behaving responsibly and fairly when it
comes to pricing all those products to
make sure that we're easing the burdens
on your weekly shop and then when it
comes to jobs I think most of you are
probably reading the paper you'll have
seen that you know businesses everywhere
really need people to work at the moment
and it's finding it hard to find them
almost everywhere so what we're doing is
reforming our welfare system to make
sure that if you can work then you
should be working shouldn't be able to
just be at home so we're going to reform
our welfare system to make sure we're
doing that but at the same time we're
also cutting the cost of child care to
make it easier for those working parents
who want to work to be able to go back
to work after they have children because
that's something that I think will make
a difference too so that's the that's
the kind of second part of the plan just
going after all those specific things
then the third part of the plan is
helping those who most need help through
the worst of this now how have we done
that well most importantly we've helped
with your energy bills you might not
know this but we actually made a
decision I made a decision when I was
your Chancellor to tax the kind of
excess profits that the energy companies
are making because of the war in Ukraine
then use that money to help pay all your
energy bills and so that support is
worth about half of your typical
family's Energy bill it's worth about 1
500 pounds of support that is what the
government has done over the past
several months now that's the scale of
what we've done it's enormous it's like
the furlough scheme quite frankly in its
size but that is now I know it's bad and
you're still looking at these bills
saying oh my gosh these are massive
bills but that's after we've taken about
1500 quid off them that gives you a
sense of how much we've tried to help on
energy but it's not just on energy we've
also providing extra help for people who
really need a bit of extra help so those
on the lowest incomes the national
living wage has gone up hopefully many
of your wages have gone up like the
national living wage over the last year
because we want to make sure those on
the lowest income see that benefit
pensioners whether it's your parents
your grandparents their state pension
has gone up several hundred pounds this
year to help them and anyone who's on
Universal Credit they're also getting an
extra 900 pounds this year of support so
those who need a little bit of extra
help are really getting that help from
the government and at the same time the
things that you know you guys do a lot
which is travel we're trying to help
there so we've cut fuel Duty which will
save you about 100 quid this year for
those of you that drive also bus fares
with cat bus fares at two pounds outside
of London just help people as they're
getting around so all those things and
we can talk later about the other things
we're doing hopefully we'll just ease
the burden as we get through the worst
of this inflation challenge but in
conclusion look I'll kind of end where I
started really is that
this this is obviously a challenge it's
a challenge that many countries are
facing right now but we are on it we're
on it and we are going to get through it
now that's not easy as I said and anyone
tells you that it's easy or can happen
overnight they're not being straight
with you right and I want to be honest
with you these things are tough
they require difficult decisions but
that's what you should get from your
government that's what you should get
from your prime minister and that's what
I'm going to do I'm going to tell it to
you straight and I'm going to do the
things that we need to do to bring
inflation down and you know I'm
confident that we're going to do that
and the reason that we can feel better
about the future is because once we get
it down that is a foundation on which we
can build a better economy right that's
how we'll create more jobs and get be
able to pay people more invest more in
public services right all those good
things that we want are built on the
foundation of getting inflation back
down and ultimately that's what I want I
want to build a better country for you
your children your grandchildren and
tackling inflation is the first thing we
need to do to build that better future
so thanks very much for having me it's
great to be here and I am open to any
and all questions before we get to the
media so who wants to kick off
yes
thing that you want to have the
inflation
so my question
so my question is
what are the economic strategies and
policies that you have in place which
can effectively achieve that objective
so it's how do we bring inflation down
well
the first and foremost way we do that is
through interest rates and that's one of
the reasons the bank of England today
put up interest rates
and that's the way that all countries
tackle inflation it's called monetary
policy when the bank of England put up
interest rates or bring down interest
rates and they put up interest rates a
lot here as they have in many other
countries because we all need to tackle
inflation now the second thing we need
to do is the government bit that I was
talking about is not borrowing too much
because if I was doing lots of things
right now that meant that the government
was going to borrow tons more money
you should look at that and say well
that's not a very sensible Economic
Policy right and anytime you hear from
politician or anyone else something that
means the government will be borrowing
more money that should set off an alarm
Bell in your heads and say hang on
inflation's really high interest rates
are already going up is that going to
make the situation better or worse it
might sound great right all those things
I talked about let's cut your taxes over
here let's spend some more money over
there let's do massive you know pay
awards for everyone in the public sector
because we really value the work they do
if I did all those things right it might
feel great for a day for a week for a
month and pretty quickly it would turn
out to have been a really bad idea right
and even if we'd given everyone an extra
pound
look through a tax cut or paying them a
lot more actually if inflation got worse
and interest rates went up we would just
be getting more than that pound back
later so that's not the right thing so
those are the kind of two elements of
the strategy that need to be right and
then the third bit is increasing the
supply of things inflation ultimately is
more people buying things than we have
supply for right that's what pushes
prices up so it's all those things I
talked about getting more workers into
the labor force for businesses
reducing the cost of child care or
forming welfare to do that getting more
energy Supply and we have a whole new
department for energy security I created
it as prime minister a department
focused solely on our energy security so
we can build more supplies of energy so
what's happened to us over the last year
never happens again right so it's making
those long-term decisions so those are
the kind of bits of the economic
strategy
is that all right good right who's next
yes
hi um I just want to ask do you have any
ideas on how to how to um help the NHS
in a moment because
um I've just spoken to some family
members of mine and they've just come up
on just to face our problems they're
right and Center like waiting 45 minutes
for an ambulance and my grandmother just
a book six months to see a doctor of GPS
what's going on like any ideas yeah lots
um so when I begin a year I talked about
that speech I made I made five set out
five priorities they were to halve
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and to stop the boats
right and we should probably talk about
all of those hopefully
um so cutting waiting list is one of my
five priorities because they're too big
right and people are waiting too long
and why is that I mean it's simple one
word covered right we had a pandemic
which lasted a very long time that was
the focus of the NHS rightly and during
that period all the people who otherwise
would have gone and got their treatment
couldn't get it didn't get it and now
they're all coming back and that's why
the backlogs are as high as they are but
I do a meeting almost every week with
the CEO of the NHS and the team and
we've got a really really good plan in
place to bring all those numbers down
what does it mean it means more doctors
more nurses more ambulances and then
being a bit cleverer about how we do
things because I know you all love the
NHS and you want me to spend lots of
money on it we're doing that but I think
all of you probably also think are we
making sure that we spend that money as
efficiently as we can right is every
pound of it being used really well and
there's lots of things we can do
differently now that will help us get
the waiting list down so I don't know
what was she where what you don't have
to tell us but if anyone's waiting for
surgery at the moment or an elective
appointment we're using things called
Community diagnostic Centers which
instead of having to go to a hospital to
get your MRI scan or your CT scan we're
building new little units next to
supermarket shopping centers which all
they do is do all the scanning so rather
than people have to go to a hospital and
then when they get there it's not ready
because someone else had an accident and
that gets rushed in we're just going to
do all the Diagnostics somewhere else
and that's really effective similarly
with surgery instead of it being all in
the same hospital where it keeps getting
disruptive when your grandmother's meant
to have an appointment and they're like
no sorry we've had this accident today
we've got a standalone unit where all
they're going to do that day is lots of
hip replacements or lots of cataract
surgery and it's not going to get
disrupted so we're rolling those out and
those are helping too so and you're
seeing the results actually I think
everyone remembers at Christmas remember
how bad it was for ambulance times you
know that's improved a lot people were
waiting an hour and a half on average
for an ambulance for a serious injury
that's come right back down to around
half an hour and we want to keep keep
that and get it improved from there so
there's a plan in place more doctors
more nurses more ambulances and more
interesting ways to use technology and
drive performance in the NHS so the
money is there don't have any doubt
about that there's a record amount of
money going in to the NHS we've just got
to make sure we use it efficiently and
and we'll you know over time we'll start
to see those waiting lists come down
and the last thing I'd say is for look
we I first wanted to go after the people
who have been waiting two years we
eliminated that last year in Spring this
year we virtually eliminated all the
people who are waiting a year and a half
right so we've virtually eliminated that
and then the next plan for next year is
to make sure we eliminate almost
everyone who's waiting one year right so
look none of those are going to be easy
right those are all challenging targets
that I've set but I really want to get
performance to be better and that's what
we're doing so that your grandmother and
everyone else gets the care they need
right who's next
ah yes sir
thank you thanks how can we ensure that
public procurement policies or supports
uh businesses domiciled here in the UK
so that we capture that value and return
it back to the exchequer through you
know public procurement
yeah so the simple answer is because of
brexit we can now do that right one of
the advantages of leaving the EU is that
we are now in charge of what's called
procurement policy what does procurement
policy mean it's the policy that you
describe is how the government and all
public organizations
do contracts how they select the people
who are going to provide services to
them and now that we've left the EU
we're in charge of writing our own rules
and we're allowed to be a little bit
different about how we do that we can
value different things for example you
know is the business providing lots of
apprenticeships in the local area
employing local people and adding all
that value that you talked about to our
UK economy so that is one of the clear
advantages of brexit we've got a new law
that's going through Parliament that
will actually Implement that program and
I think it's going to be great for
particularly small businesses I think
big businesses are generally quite good
at navigating all these these rules but
particularly for small and medium-sized
businesses this is going to be a real
benefit and it's going to be great for
the UK economy but it's one of the
Practical examples of something we're
doing differently after we left the EU
yes sir
Hello nice to have you
um I'm here today uh really fortunate to
be here today with some of the Ikea
Future Leaders and um and we work very
much in a values-based leadership you've
described some of the really difficult
decisions you have to make every day I
just wonder on a personal level what are
the core values that inform your
leadership style
right where are they here who where are
these young are they scaff hands up in
the air who are you right here they all
are brilliant so you're they on a
leadership training program ah great
will you guys tell me actually what do
you guys think is important
um
we treat people respectfully so it's
about looking after each other they're
the important things about leading and
communicating the why is so important as
well
um I think for me as well it majorly
comes to Leading by example so I'm
treating people how you expect to be
treated yourself
um being very open and honest about you
know hard times as well as good times so
that as a leader you can come across as
somebody who is relatable and
um you can lead then in a strong way
um but absolutely as Alicia said it
comes down to connecting our own
personal values to the IKEA values as
well
um yeah I think for me togetherness is
really really important and showing that
actually across our company we all are
going after the same thing in the same
like core values are important to all of
us I think championing this movement
with sustainability and showcasing the
right way forward with that and then
making sure that it's communicated
across all levels and it's not something
exclusive yeah now you know what a lot
of what you said I try and do as well
actually which uh and all of you picked
on a similar theme which is about being
honest good times and bad integrity and
trying to do things together I think for
political leadership that's really
important because I think all of you
need to have trust in your politicians
and that comes from a couple of things I
think it comes from me being honest with
you
in good times and in bad about what
we're facing what it's going to take to
fix it not promising you know Solutions
I know are not going to work just
because they sound good or make my life
easier right that's not acting with
integrity that's not being honest with
people and I think people can see
through that so like I always try as I'm
doing now as we're talking about the
economy and inflation not sugar coating
that this is tough and it's hard but
we're going to get through it and that's
going to mean we need to take some
difficult decisions sometimes so I think
that's an important part of building
that trust and then the second thing is
delivering on the things that you say
which again kind of you guys touched on
and I think lots of politics in the past
has been people promise a lot of things
and you know then it never actually
happens you know I want to restore
people's trust in politics by or just
being honest about what we're doing and
how we're doing it but then actually
delivering on the things that I say
right so I'm not going to promise the
Earth right
probably I can fix every single problem
but I say like here are my five
priorities I've set them out really
clearly and you guys should be able to
hold me to account right in six months
nine months a year year and a half you
can kind of say are you making progress
on the things that you said you were
going to make progress on are those the
right things for the country and for my
family and then you can make a judgment
about how I'm doing right but it's got
to be about delivery not just about
talking it's got to be actually doing
things you know your grandmother needs
to get her appointment and someone
else's grandmother when something
happens to them that the ambulance comes
on time like these things need to feel
like they're getting better not worse
right and that's what I'm about doing
and it's that's how you restore trust in
politics I'm a different type of
politician I want to change things that
people do have trust and that is about
being honest with them and about
delivering on the things you say it's
actually very similar to what you guys
said
all right who uh yes sir at the back
uh so Recent research by uh generation
Logistics showed that 90 of young people
won't consider Logistics as a career
whilst 40 of those uh see it as critical
to the UK's success and so how important
do you think it is that more young
Talent consider Logistics as a career of
choice and how can we achieve that
well I of course it's important right I
mean you guys are like the lifeblood of
our economy nothing happens without you
and your colleagues doing the same jobs
across the country being involved in it
right like everything that happens has
to happen through people like you
businesses like yours right so we can't
have a functioning economy without all
of you so it's actually Mission critical
um to how we live our lives and
everything that we're used to so I think
that's a pretty compelling reason to go
into it and the good news is that it's
growing right your industry is growing
right which is fantastic look the
hundreds of jobs that are created here
by that investment you know good jobs
doing interesting things and the best
way I think to get young people into it
is through things like apprenticeships
and I think it's showing young people
that there's an exciting path into this
new career that they can get into quite
quickly where they can study and earn at
the same time they can do it with other
people and that they can see there's a
career ahead of them when they can
progress and keep learning new skills
and you know you guys will have that
opportunity right and that's fantastic
when you work for good companies who are
providing those opportunities it's it's
a really compelling vision and we just
got to get out there and communicate it
and you know one thing when it comes to
apprenticeships right a lot of the focus
in the past was all on everyone going to
University we've got to make sure
everyone realizes apprenticeships are an
incredible option for people we really
improve the quality of them they work
brilliantly and one of the small things
we can we've done which will make a
difference is you know those of us that
went to University will remember the
ucas form right as that big kind of
thing that you have to do it's a whole
process everyone's focused on it for the
first time now we've moved
apprenticeships onto the ucas system
right in the process of doing that so it
doesn't feel like it's a whole different
thing that it's less of the University
it's like hang on there's lots of
different options they're all great
right and actually you should be able to
apply and find them all on the same
system so small practical things like
that mean that someone will see an
opportunity that might not have
considered before and I think ah
actually you know what that worked for
me and I'm sure if any of your friends
spend time with any of you or came here
they'd be pretty inspired by what all of
you are doing and the skills you're
learning and the careers you've got and
that's probably the best thing we can do
is uh get you guys filming a bunch of
videos and put that out there right
good right so
yeah thank you um you mentioned
apprenticeships and I I totally agree
they're really important Avenue for us
to build skills at wincanton
um we have around about 335 people on
program at the moment we're big
supporters of apprenticeships but yet we
only utilize about 54 of our Levy and we
work really hard at using the levy as
best we can so there's been discussion
about reforms I understand around the
apprenticeship Levy making it more
flexible so that we can give a broader
pool of colleagues opportunities for
upskilling any update on the reforms
please yeah so I know it's something
that the Department of Education and the
treasury are talking to businesses about
and so
conversation is ongoing one thing we
have done which should help you is allow
big companies to spend their love Levy
or transfer it to smaller medium-sized
businesses in their supply chain so I
think that is a relatively new thing
that I think came enforced last year and
that will allow you to transfer a bulk
of your budget into even if it's not
your own company it's companies that
work through your supply chain that was
something that businesses talked to me
about when I was Chancellor and I was
pleased to put that in place
um so hopefully that will help and
there's always kind of an ongoing
conversation about what's the right Flex
in the apprenticeship system look we
went you know for those of you that
don't know how this works you know this
is the apprenticeship library is
something that big companies pay they
pay an apprenticeship Levy it goes into
account and then they can use that
account to spend on apprenticeships and
because we want to make sure that
businesses are investing in their
workforces and that's a good way to make
sure they do it and your point is could
we spend it on things that are not just
apprenticeships but maybe other skills
qualifications as well and our
challenges we think apprenticeships are
brilliant and the gold stand did and if
there was going to be Flex We want to
make sure that we're not diluting the
quality of the training that people are
getting so that's the conversations that
that they're having but it's as I said
we've already made some changes on the
small companies and Supply chains and I
know that they're talking about doing
more
there was a question behind you yes sir
I think what we're seeing today is a
really good example of two organizations
working together strategically to
deliver a supply chain solution and I
guess my question really is when we work
in the public sector it's not
necessarily as strategic it's more
tactical so what advice would you give
an organization like Wing Canton to work
more tactically with the public sector
customers and probably more importantly
who do we talk to
gosh
um well I've got someone here on my
teams you can talk to them after after
we're finished I'll get them to come
wave at you um but look I'd like to
think actually we should be working more
strategically in the public sector too
right I mean I I don't want to hear that
it's somehow only tactical because I
think back to the gentleman's question
before about procurement right actually
it's you know the government should be
having good strategic Partnerships with
companies in the private sector you know
where they can deliver good things for
the country right that's obviously
better for everybody
um so and companies that have that
certainty or slightly longer term
contracts that can then invest in their
workforces properly knowing that they've
got that contract for a few years those
seem like sensible things for the
government to be doing I don't think we
are doing it but I'll make sure that we
get someone to talk to you afterwards
about how we can help you guys
specifically
right any uh any any other questions
all good
all right fine okay so we'll turn we've
got some media questions I've probably
got a list somewhere here let's see uh
right should we start with um uh can we
start with ITV
uh prime minister you'll be aware that
markets are today
discounting a significant risk of
recession
um of falling house prices rising
unemployment recession
a price worth paying to get inflation
down
um and secondly just talk very
eloquently
about the need to restore trust in
politics and politicians you haven't yet
told us whether you agree with the
Privileges committee reporting to Boris
Johnson do you agree with it
right so look on on your first question
Robert like nobody wants to see a
recession of course I don't want to see
a recession no one wants to see a
recession and actually part of the
reason that we're seeing inflation be
higher than we had anticipated
previously is because the economy has
done better I don't know if you guys
remember everyone was forecasting that
the UK would go into a recession this
year
and that hasn't happened right kind of
divide everyone's expectation because
the economy is performing well jobs like
yours are all being created companies
are growing unemployment is at a very
low level you know and that is a of
course that is all a good thing
um but it's meant that the inflation
challenge has become a little bit
tougher uh so look I always want to make
sure that we're trying to grow the
economy but as I said halving inflation
on its way down to two percent that's
the right priority because all the good
things that we want more jobs higher
wages more investment in Public Services
Lower taxes all those things we can't
have any of those things unless we get
inflation back down and then get
interest rates coming down again right
that has got to be the priority
um anyone who tells you that there's
some Shortcut is not doing straight with
you right as much as I wish there was
there isn't so we've got to stick to the
course and that's what's going to guide
my actions throughout all of this um
looking on your on your second question
the Privileges I have enormous
respect for the Privileges committee
support the Privileges committee and
indeed respect the vote of the house
that we had on Monday regarding Boris
Johnson but what I'd also say is look
I'm not focused on the past right um I
want to look forward right like this now
Boris Johnson is no longer a member of
parliament it's right that people
whoever they are whatever position they
hold face the the results of their
actions that they're held accountable
for their actions that's happened he's
no longer a member of parliament right
we've got to focus on the future and
that's what I'm doing as your prime
minister I think that's what you want me
to do is focus on all the things that
we're talking we've talked about today
and with regard to that in general you
know I wasn't I wasn't there to vote
because I was at a charity dinner as as
you know but look I'm someone who took a
very difficult decision
a while ago to resign from Boris
Johnson's government right it's not an
easy thing to do to resign as being
Chancellor right that's kind of a big
deal I did that because as I said at the
time I disagreed with his approach to
government right so I think that tells
you that I'm prepared to act
according to my values and the standards
that I want to see and that wasn't
happening I said I didn't agree with the
approach I said that in my resignation
letter and that's why I resigned right
so like in terms of that particular
thing because I think standards matter
as I think you said at Alicia first
right like Integrity matters it matters
in business it matters in public life
too and I want to act in a way that
means you guys can have confidence that
I'm acting with Integrity with
professionalism and there's
accountability
as you saw in that situation there was
accountability and you guys would be
able to hold me to account for
delivering all the things that we've
talked about today
right next Sky News
thank you prime minister you said today
you want to be honest that you're
someone who is straight with people are
you being straight when you say that
everything is going to be okay that
we're 100 going to get through this that
you will halve inflation by the end of
the year do you regret making that a
personal priority and should people
trust you if that doesn't happen and can
I also ask you're basically asking
people to kind of hold their nerve and
suffer pain in the medium term do you
think that will cost you do you accept
that will cost you the battle box so
I absolutely don't think it was a
mistake to set as my number one priority
halving inflation right I am ambitious
for our country and I want to deliver on
the things that are going to make most
difference to all of you and your
families and we've got to get inflation
down and at the time I set that Target
actually lots of people said it wasn't
ambitious enough that it was too easy
and I knew that that wasn't true
right I knew at the time that actually
getting inflation down would be tough
right and I wanted to set an ambitious
Target that would we would work really
hard to get to I'm sure when you talk to
your young leaders you guys talk and
your business is about setting ambitious
targets right you don't you know you
will strive to get them and look has it
got harder yeah of course it's got
harder to meet that Target the last
couple of months have shown that it's
got harder but it's certainly not
impossible and I'm gonna still give
absolutely everything I've got to
delivering on it and more broadly like
we've got to keep getting inflation down
because even once it's halved that's not
enough we've got to get it all the way
back down to two percent that's our
normal inflation Target but I wanted to
say very clearly this was a priority and
something I'm working towards and look
everyone will be able to make you guys
will be the judges of that right and
you'll be able to see where we are in
six months nine months a year and you'll
see how I'm doing and whether I'm doing
everything I can whether you think it's
reasonable or not but I'll leave that up
to you but I just want to let you know
that I think that is priority number one
and I'm doing everything I can to bring
it down and that is how you will restore
trust in politics it's because you set
out very clearly what you're going to do
then you go about your hardest to
deliver it and then people can be the
judges of whether that's worked or not
um GB news
thank you
um yesterday to secure stomach prime
minister's questions you spoke about
Labor policy that in your view would
raise inflation you've mentioned some of
those things today you mentioned Banning
supplies of new energy in the North Sea
about giving in to unions unaffordable
pay demands you said that would make the
situation worse yet when you became
prime minister you raised benefits by
10.1 percent you raised pensions by 10.1
percent and you reversed recent
liberalizations to onshore wind Supply
and indeed Shale gas exploration in your
words would that not make the situation
worse too and just in addition if I may
the conservative party is putting out
literature in the Uxbridge and South
ruislip by-election attacking the
liberal democrats for a target of 300
000 homes a year is that no longer the
government's targets right so I'm going
to try just so we can get in a few of
your colleagues if everyone tries not to
have multiple questions otherwise we
won't be able to get everyone else in
and we hear from some others um look I
firmly believe that labor party policy
would make the situation worse 100 do I
believe that right and I've tried not to
get into too much politics in these
things but you know what do we know the
labor party policy is to borrow 28
billion pounds a year
right so I yeah you know my view I think
borrowing huge amounts of money uh at a
time when we're facing Rising interest
rates and inflation is not a good idea
it might be that all the things that
that would be spent on are things that
people think well that sounds great I'd
like a bit of that but I'm telling you
doing that at a time like this is the
wrong thing to do it would make the
situation worse and I wouldn't do that
yes labor party policy is to not do any
more exploration of energy supplies in
the naughty I think that's a mistake
right I believe in Net Zero we're going
to get to Net Zero but we're going to
get there in decades not overnight
between now and then we are still going
to need oil and gas and if we've got
supplies of oil and gas here in the UK
it seems to me absurd not to use those a
because it will create jobs but B
because it improves our energy security
and it reduces inflation so you know
we've seen over the last year what
happens when you know energy dictators
around the world are able to hold us to
Ransom right so actually cutting off our
own supplies of energy seems to be an
incredibly short-sided policy it would
definitely make situation was and lastly
on public sector pay again right look I
value our public sector workers they do
an incredible job whether they're in the
NHS whether they're teachers right all
all of them right now of course everyone
would like to be paid more but I have to
be cognizant of what we can afford
what's responsible and it is it would be
being dishonest with people to say okay
great I'm going to borrow a ton of money
so I can give you a generous pay rise
make my life easier for a bit but
knowing full well that all I've done is
fuel more inflation and higher interest
rates and that extra pay packet you got
one month ultimately is just going to
get eaten up and then some because we're
dealing with more inflation down the
line right I'm not going to do that it
is difficult for me of course it's
difficult for me would my life be easier
if I was able to say yes to everyone it
would be but it's the wrong thing for
all of you it's a wrong thing for the
country and it's also the wrong thing
for those public sector workers as I
said because they will also pay the
price of higher inflation in the long
run so like that's my Approach on that
um BBC
thank you prime minister Chris Mason BBC
News you've said today you've tried to
reassure people this afternoon that it's
going to be okay isn't the blunt truth
that for some people it won't be okay if
you're going to be able to get inflation
down
well Chris I've never said this is going
to be easy
right like getting inflation down I've
always said this is going to be tough
and it's going to take time but I'm
determined to do it and it's right that
we do it because in the long run that is
the best way to help everyone because
inflation eats away at the money in your
pocket and that's wrong and that's why I
feel a deep moral responsibility to get
it down and I'm prepared to do what it
takes to do that that does mean making
some difficult decisions but those are
the right decisions for the country in
the long run because if we don't get a
grip of this it will just get worse and
it will last for longer and it hurts
particularly those on the lowest incomes
right inflation is always the worst for
people who are the most vulnerable and
that's why as I said I feel a deep more
responsibility to get it down and that's
what we're determined to do right and
I'm being straight with people it's not
easy it will take time and it requires
difficult decisions but that's what
responsible leadership looks like we
talked about it we heard it very
eloquently from all three of you right
that's the type of leaders you aspire to
be that's a the leader that I am and
that's what the government's going to
deliver
we've got the ft
hi uh it's Anna gross from the financial
times
um you warned about the risk of
inflation when you were Chancellor do
you think that the bank of England has
moved uh too slowly has done too little
too late to tame inflation
so I support the bank of England in what
they're doing and I'd point back to what
I said earlier what we're grappling with
here as a country is something that many
other countries are grappling with at
the same time set interest rates in
America in Canada in Australia in New
Zealand as I mentioned all pretty
similar to the interest rates here
interest rates in the in Europe are at
the highest they've been in in 20 years
right just to give you some context and
all central banks around the world are
worried about the Persistence of
inflation and are taking steps to bring
it down by raising interest rates so as
I said like that is the global context
for what we're facing you know it's it's
not unique to the UK and it's right that
the bank of England takes a strong
action to bring inflation down they've
got a Target to get it back down to two
percent it's right that they deliver on
that because ultimately right it is the
best thing for the country right there
is no short-term easy fix to this
there's no shortcut anyone standing here
telling you there's some Shortcut is not
being straight with you right so those
of us who are responsible for this have
to take the responsible decisions in the
long-term interests of our country and
all of you that's what I'm doing and
that's what the bank of English are
doing too
and lastly we've got the telegraph
thanks prime minister Dominic panerami
Telegraph is there now zero chance for a
major attacks Court this year or is that
something that is still possible and
your own back benches who are calling
for tax cuts are they being
irresponsible
so it goes back to what I said to all of
you before right would I love to cut
your taxes tomorrow yeah of course I
would right I mean I'm I'm a politician
I'm a conservative politician who
wouldn't want to cut people's taxes
right like do you think if I thought
that was a good thing to do I wouldn't
have done it of course I would right but
it goes back to what I was saying before
right borrowing lots of money to do
things that sound great isn't the
responsible approach it's not going to
help anyone in the long run and at the
same when I talk about public sector pay
tax cut spending you know ultimately if
the government is having to borrow money
to do all those things it just puts fuel
on the fire of inflation makes it worse
makes it last longer means interest
rates will go up even more and that's
not going to do anyone any favors and
you talk about tax cuts you know what
the biggest tax cut that this government
could deliver for you and for everyone
else is to halve inflation
right that is a massive tax cut because
there is inflation right now that is
making everyone poorer that is eating
into the pounds in your pocket it's
eroding your paychecks it's pushing out
the prices of everything it's eating
into your savings pushing up interest
rates inflation is the tax right so if
we can halve inflation and then get it
down to two percent over time right that
is the biggest tax cut we could deliver
so that's what I'm focused on to
all right good well look guys thank you
so much for having me it's been great
it's really nice to meet you
particularly you guys who I thought were
incredibly eloquent talking about what
you're doing it actually just fills me
with enormous confidence right because
and I talk about this and yeah we've got
some tough stuff to get through we will
get through it and we should be
confident about the future because of
people like you right talking so in such
an inspiring way about what you want to
do when your careers progress your story
replicated across the country is why all
of us should have confidence in the
future of our country because we've got
great days ahead of us and people like
you are going to help us realize it my
job is to give you every opportunity and
support your success and that's what I'm
trying to do good thanks very much
everyone bye-bye
[Applause]